[Applauso]
[Musica]
vorrei con vuoi condividere questa
mattina una riflessione che tocca
quattro punti del contratto ma vorrei
far questo innanzitutto cominciando come
immagine con qualcosa che forse si
avvicina molta dove ci troviamo se
ballabile lo studente qui alla fine
siamo alla metà del 1200
qui a donare di idee corrado iv sta per
fondare la città questa minuta hoc che
nasce con con grandi desideri con grande
stile con grandi progetti nello stesso
tempo mentre qui all'aquila c'è questo
grande cantiere in cui sta nascendo
questa città siamo la metà del 1200
c'è un ragazzo un giovane che è nato a
roccasecca vicino montecassino litigando
un po con la famiglia vuole seguire in
maniera più radicale il messaggio di
cristo cerca un ordine che possa un po
corrispondergli ha studiato monito ha
studiato con i benedettini ha respirato
la cultura dell'epoca ma lui cerca
qualcosa che ancora più radicale e trova
nell'ordine dei domenicani questa
corrispondenza tra la ricerca della
verità e la ricerca di qualcosa di
grande di chi veramente evangelico su
cui fondare la propria vita questo
ragazzo questo giovane si chiama tommaso
dopo aver studiato un po in italia va a
studiare all'estero prima a parigi poi a
colonia poi ritorna a parigi e lo
ritroviamo proprio lì ma la meta del
1250 questo giovane che ha lasciato casa
contestato un po tutto questo per
cercare il compatto con la propria
vocazione il compatto con qualcosa che
possa realizzare la sua vita è lì a
parigi compie un gesto gesto
rivoluzionario un gesto sovversivo si
mette a leggere
etico si mette a leggere aristotele che
era assolutamente vietato leggere
all'epoca tommaso legge l'eretico
aristotele e leggendo telesia diciamo
del aristotele riesce a ripensare tutto
il pensiero cristiano proprio a partire
dal punto di vista di aristotele trova
una maniera geniale di raccontare il
cristianesimo con un alfabeto che
diventa ad un tratto più comprensibile
più chiaro più ragionevole la grandezza
del pensiero di tommaso e riuscire a
prendere le persone per mano e ad
accompagnare le domanda risposta con
grande logica verso quella che dovrebbe
essere la consapevolezza della della
verità
ed è proprio lui che ha fatto questo
gesto rivoluzionario di mettersi a
leggere un eretico il contatto col
eresia che forse ci suggerisce la prima
chiave di lettura l'eresia non è mai
qualcosa contro di noi
l'eresia è qualcosa di diverso e la
diversità è una grande opportunità per
ciascuno di noi perché ciò che è diverso
ci aiuta non sa perdere noi stessi ma
trovare il modo migliore per potergli
dire noi stessi
e proprio nella diversità che la nostra
identità emergere nella maniera più più
bella più chiara quando abbiamo paura
dell'eresia quando abbiamo paura della
diversità in fondo è perché siamo molto
insicuri in fondo è perché non sappiamo
davvero chi siamo e per questo ci
chiudiamo dentro noi stessi ma tommaso
che ha fatto qualcosa di rivoluzionario
alla metà del 1200
in realtà copia questo format dal
fondatore del cristianesimo che gesù è
bello pensare quando si leggono i
racconti del vangelo che i più grandi
complimenti che oggi si paga ad esempio
se su fa nei racconti evangelici gli fa
ad eretici cioè a persone che sono fuori
dal popolo d'israele samaritani ad
esempio erano così considerati diversi
così fuori erano considerati come dei
cani degli stray liti che non bisognava
nemmeno rivolgere la parola a queste
persone
eppure gesù fa complimenti a sammaritani
pensate alla pari
ora del buon samaritano mentre un
sacerdote un levita passano accanto a un
uomo che è morto a terra perché lo hanno
derubato e picchiato il samaritano
lo straniero il diverso si ferma e a
compassione per quell'uomo un altro
complimento lo fa nei confronti di una
donna che già per il fatto di essere
donna porta in sé un eresia è una donna
è una donna e in più e cananea riesce a
strappare uno dei più grandi miracoli a
gesù proprio quando gesù sembra non
rivolgerle la parola è interessante
perché questa dimensione di integrare la
diversità dentro la nostra vita non
riguarda mai semplicemente gli altri
l'insegnamento di cristo e capire che in
fondo noi abbiamo bisogno di ritrovare
un contatto con la diversità che ci
abita con l'eresia che ci abita
cioè con tutto quello che di
contraddittorio c'è dentro la nostra
vita e noi normalmente non lo accettiamo
perché non riusciamo a metterlo dentro
lo schema
ecco quello che vi ho appena spiegato è
la definizione laica di che cosa sia la
misericordia ed entrare in contatto con
la nostra miseria senza giudicarla
ma amando la nostra miseria il nostro
scarto quando una persona si sente
accolta nella propria miseria si ritrova
la vita cambiata rivoluzionata la
teologia usa il nome convertita per
questo gesù non ha paura ad esempio di
entrare in contatto con peccatori
prostitute con pubblicani e nel circuito
delle sue compagne e ci sono persone
esattamente così quello che fa
esternamente in fondo invita a farlo
anche dentro ciascuno di noi
il contatto con la diversità il contatto
con quello che noi chiamiamo eresia in
fondo è una riconciliazione con la
diversità che ci abita con quello che è
dentro la nostra vita non riusciamo ad
integrare perché a volte non troviamo
nemmeno le parole per poter raccontare
questo ma è tommaso torniamo a lui che
proprio mentre le già ristò tele
l'eretico aristotele trova una
definizione di contatto secondo me
geniale dice che la verità e adeguarsi o
rey ed intelletto
che tradotto significa che noi
consideriamo una cosa vera quanto la
realtà corrisponde al nostro intelletto
ora senza entrare in tematiche
filosofiche la genialità di tommaso e
dire che una cosa è vera è la verità di
qualcosa la si stabilisce dal fatto che
la realtà è in relazione in contatto con
la nostra testa è che se tu vuoi
scoprire se qualcosa è davvero vera devi
metterti in gioco ed entrare dentro la
realtà devi trovare un contatto con la
realtà non puoi trovare la realtà chiuso
in una parte lontana non basta
semplicemente la logica anche se una
cosa vera per essere vera bisogno di
essere logica c'è qualcosa dice tommaso
che non dobbiamo mai perdere di vista
cioè il contatto con il real e il
predominio della realtà il dato contro
anche i nostri pregiudizi contro i
nostri ragionamenti con contro le
logiche che a volte ci abitano contatto
di verità significa entrare in relazione
con la con la realtà ecco queste due
dimensioni credo che siano importanti la
vita di ciascuno di noi
noi ci accorgiamo che se entriamo in
contatto con la diversità è incontrato
pulite in contatto con il real e ci
accorgiamo in fondo che la nostra vita
comincia ad allargarsi a non essere più
ristretta ci accorgiamo che il abilità e
appunto un'esperienza non è
semplicemente una formula non è
semplicemente un'idea che pu riesce a
dire nel migliore dei modi è appunto una
relazione un contatto che cambia
completamente la tua vita ma penso che
ciascuno di noi guardando un po la
propria esistenza si accorge che non
basta questo
ognuno di noi non ha solo bisogno di
riconciliarsi con la propria eresia e
non ha semplicemente soltanto bisogno di
entrare il rapporto con la realtà c'è
un'altra dimensione che riempie un po
tutta la nostra esistenza
un contatto che più grande della realtà
stessa e cioè noi vogliamo trovare un
contatto con noi stessi con la nostra
parte più profonda il nome di questo
contatto e interiorità e noi abbiamo
sacco paura dell'interiorità cioè
abbiamo paura di tornare dentro noi
stessi perché abbiamo paura che la
verità di noi stessi non ci piaccia
allora tutto il nostro percorso e
cercare qualcosa che ci renda profondi
che cosa opponiamo alla parola
profondità la parola superficialità
quando diciamo che una persona e
superficiale diciamo in fondo che i suoi
ragionamenti il suo modo di vivere il
suo modo di fare le sue scelte sono
mediocri non conducono da nessuna parte
non sono degne di essere chiamate
veramente vieta una persona che è
superficiale in fondo non può mai
davvero essere felice soprattutto non
riesce mai a rendere felice alle altre
persone invece l'investimento
nell'intero rita significa dare a
qualcuno la capacità di avere una
profondità un fondamento qualcosa che
possa aiutarlo a reggere la vita e
perché noi abbiamo bisogno di questa
interiorità perché noi siamo tormentati
dall'idea di capire chi siamo davvero lo
abbiamo ascoltato prima anche dagli
altri relatori ci siamo accorti in fondo
che a volte lui troppo in fretta
vogliamo dare una definizione di noi
stessi noi pensiamo di essere quello che
i genitori ci hanno messo addosso le
aspettative degli altri
poi ci accorgiamo che sono troppo
strette queste aspettative degli altri a
volte le demoniaco gli ambienti che
abitiamo ci mettono addosso un'identità
una cultura che abitiamo ci suggeriscono
un identità ciascuno di noi
costruisce costantemente il proprio nome
ma si accorge che manca sempre qualcosa
che ognuno di noi è sempre un mistero a
se stesso diceva qualcuno che il nostro
vero nome
lo abbiamo attuato sulla nostra nuca e
non riusciamo a leggerlo da soli abbiamo
bisogno sempre che qualcuno ci lega che
qualcuno ci aiuti a decifrare qual è la
nostra vera identità chi siamo veramente
noi allora l'interiorità più che
raggiungere uno sfogo un cammino un
percorso e comprendere che per tutta la
vita tu pensi qualcosa di te stesso e
poi l'esperienza smentisce demolisce
si rimette in piedi una persona che
soffre una una società che vive un
terremoto una tragedia pensava qualcosa
di sé e poi un terremoto demolisce
completamente questo pensiero
questa identità allora la rinascita la
ricostruzione significa cercare ancora
una volta quale in questo nome
una pandemia che riempie il mondo lo
affligge ha messo in crisi il nostro
sistema la nostra identità pensavamo che
bastasse funzionare che ci siamo accorti
invece che basta qualcosa di
infinitamente piccolo a mettere in
discussione tutto il nostro meccanismo
tutta la nostra vita e cercare questo
nome contatto con noi stessi contatto
con la nostra identità per di qualcuno
mette al mondo un figlio ti innamori 6
tradito sei ferito vivi una grande gioia
tutto questo è come una sorta di mappa e
noi siamo come chiamati a cercare questo
tipo di contatto contatto con la nostra
diversità contatto con il reale contatto
con noi stessi ma anche questo a noi non
basta perché dopo che abbiamo capito che
lì in fondo una persona riconciliata e
una persona che può guardare davanti a
se una persona che non ha accettato la
propria diversità guarda solo i propri
piedi e sempre preoccupata di difendersi
o di affermare gli altri è sempre
preoccupata di dover convincere gli
altri di non essere sbagliato di non
essere fuori luogo ma in fondo questa
difensiva questo essere sempre ripiegati
su noi stessi
viene dal fatto che noi non abbiamo
ancora accettato noi stessi non ci siamo
ancora riconciliati le persone
riconciliate alzano lo sguardo riescono
a guardare in fondo capiscono che il
viaggio non è convincere qualcuno
il viaggio lo è andare da qualche parte
avere un orizzonte di senso non basta
essere riconciliati però anche se
necessario alzare lo sguardo e
accorgersi che la maggior parte della
nostra vita a volte noi la viviamo
dentro la nostra testa
passiamo molto del nostro tempo
rinchiusi i nostri ragionamenti che
assorbono un sacco delle nostre energie
psichiche effettive spirituali fisiche e
non ci accorgiamo invece che la vita è
fuori
dentro la realtà è che guardare un fiore
toccare la sabbia mettersi davanti al
sole toccare qualcuno entrare in
contatto con reale è infinitamente più
grande di tutto quello che si può
passare dentro nella nostra testa è che
a volte assorbe i nostri pomeriggi le
nostre notti i nostri alle nostre
settimane anni interi della nostra vita
ripassiamo dentro noi stessi a
progettare a salmodiare a lamentarci
quando tu ti accorgi che c'è un valore
aggiunto a uscire se stessi tu ti
accorgi che la realtà è sempre più
grande della potesta ed è bellissima
anche quante drammatica è che c'è una
storia bellissima che emerge la dalla
trilogia di matrix
perché quelle persone che si ritrovano
lì davanti a me l'abbiamo ascoltato
anche prima davanti alla scelta di stare
dentro un sistema e di dall'illusione
della realtà e metterti fuori da un
sistema invece che non ha nessun incanto
c'è nessuno mantici smo e la realtà nuda
e cruda c'è qualcuno che da fuori vuole
tornare dentro l'illusione ma c'è
qualcuno che è da dentro l'illusione
vuole andare nella realtà vera perchè si
accorge che la vita vale la pena se tu
ti svegli la mattina e di viveur
qualcosa di vero non per una storia che
i racconti ti acconci che ha
assolutamente bisogno della realtà anche
quando la realtà è difficile da
accettare perché è vera
appunto perché il real è uno dei più
grandi santi nella storia del
cristianesimo e francesco d'assisi
francesco d'assisi diceva ai suoi frati
quando entravano in paranoia la paranoia
la grande malattia che attraversa un po
le nostre vite
la paranoia e quando un dettaglio della
tua vita diventa totalizzante quando
tutti i fissi su qualcosa e non riesce a
vedere nient'altro
una persona una situazione una ferita
una sofferenza un sogno progetto entri
talmente tanto in paranoia che non
riesci a guardare più la realtà è che
accorgi di essere entrato in paranoia
perché quel pensiero e angosciante
toglie energia toglie vita fa diminuire
la vita ti fa desiderare la morte
francesco aveva un antidoto
straordinario a questo tipo di problema
diceva ai suoi frati quando entravano
impara
noi ha mai all'orto non è una punizione
toccare la terra entrare in contatto
vivo con la natura aiutava moltissimo le
persone a uscire dalla propria paranoia
a tornare appunto al real è lui che si
era convertito non per ragionamento ma
perché un giorno aveva vinto la sua
diversità le sue resistenze abbracciando
un lebbroso il contatto con un uomo che
poteva farlo ammalare il contatto con un
contagioso questo e francesco d'assisi
ma tutto questo ancora non basta ecco il
quarto e ultimo contatto che vorrei
condividere con voi
ognuno di noi non è soltanto ricerca
ricerca di se stesso ricerca di
riconciliazione ricerca di realtà ognuno
di noi in ricerca di senso perché cos'è
il senso e trovare qualcosa che ti ha
significato alla nostra vita che appunto
non la faccia semplicemente funzionare
ma che la riempie di una gratitudine che
non viene dal semplice funzionamento non
basta avere la salute un lavoro una casa
delle persone intorno per dire siamo
felici una persona è felice quando
quello che sta facendo anche se faticoso
e significativo questa è la ricerca del
senso la religione chi ama questo senso
dio ma anche se tu non hai la fede
questo senso lo cerchi tutti noi
cerchiamo qualcosa di significativo
qualcosa che non ci faccia funzionare ma
ci faccia essere felici avevano capito
anche coloro che nell'antichità avevano
pensato queste grandi storie come
paradigma un po della nostra troppo
logie in tutta lì via dello disse a noi
troviamo ulisse che cerca cioè che cerca
di tornare a casa cerca questa
riconciliazione vuole tornare
un'appartenenza vorrei tornare al suo
nome ma la storia ci dice che quando
ulisse torna a casa dopo che vince non
riesce a stare ad itaca va via perché
perché noi viviamo un conflitto
grandissimo siamo creature finite e
questa è un'evidenza perché moriamo
tutti ma abbiamo un grande desiderio
infinito per cuore
abbiamo bisogno di una cosa che più
grande
nelle nostre possibilità e che ci spinge
ad andare oltre e ancora oltre
non è la ricerca di dio per trovare una
consolazione ai mali della vita e la
ricerca di un dio che ci metta in
contatto con questo infinito che c'è
dentro ciascuno di noi che cambia
ciascuno di noi che riempie la nostra
vita di significato
ecco allora c'è una poesia bellissima è
un poeta inglese che dice così che è
tutto l'universo in fondo ognuno di noi
lo ritrova nel frammento incontrare dio
incontrare un senso significa incontrare
qualcuno o qualcosa che intercetta
questo infinito e ti dice che esiste ed
è in quel momento ed è davanti a te
grazie
[Applauso]